annas mutter money & science elfi mit
der kanzlerin und angela merkel tröstet
rehm sowie zwei begegnungen aus dem jahr
2015 auch im jahr 2015 die
bundeskanzlerin auf ihrer
sommerpressekonferenz wir haben so
vieles geschafft wir schaffen das damals
sind hunderttausende auf dem weg durch
europa auf der flucht vor krieg terror
und gewalt in deutschland treffen sie
auf entgegenkommen und hilfsbereitschaft
aber auch auf ablehnung
im september 2015 schießt annas mutter
molly sein spontanes elfi mit der
kanzlerin als diese das flüchtlingsheim
in berlin-spandau besucht
heute lebt der 23 jährige syrer noch
immer in berlin studiert
wirtschaftskommunikation im zweiten
semester
außerdem arbeitet er als kassierer in
einem supermarkt in deutschland haben
sich in den vergangenen fünf jahren mehr
als 10.000 geflüchtete immatrikuliert
tendenz steigend gut 363.000 flüchtlinge
gehen aktuell einer
sozialversicherungspflichtigen
beschäftigung nach seine freundin anna
kommt ursprünglich aus der ukraine
die beiden haben sich an der hochschule
kennen gelernt seit zwei monaten wohnen
sie zusammen
ich habe mich schnell integriert in die
kultur ich kann damit gut umgehen ich
habe die sprache gelernt es ist immer
hat mich doch nicht so perfekt aber ich
arbeite und daran und ich lerne immer
noch mehr dazu einen deutschen pass hat
er bislang nicht
er genießt sogenannten subsidiären
schutz darf also bleiben bei einem
bürgerdialog im juli 2015 trifft angela
merkel auf die schülerin riemser wie sie
kam 2010 für eine medizinische
behandlung aus einem flüchtlingslager im
libanon nach deutschland
ihr aufenthaltsstatus war damals nicht
gesichert aber es wären manche auch
wieder zurückgehen müssen
daraufhin bricht in tränen aus
von 2015 bis 2019 werden fasst 116.000
geflüchtete aus deutschland abgeschoben
prima will darf bleiben sie geht in
rostock zur schule will ihr abitur
machen und studieren team fühlt sich in
deutschland angekommen
integration heißt sie nicht in dem sinne
jetzt dass ich die sprache spreche dass
ich meine freunde gefunden habe dass ich
bestimmte kulturelle werte die ich
mitgenommen habe ja einbringen kann
integration ist einfach eine art von
angekommen sein
und das denke ich habe ich inzwischen
gut hinbekommen
[Musik]
im sommer 2015 haben die beiden für
symbolträchtige bilder gesorgt heute
sind sie live freuen hier zu gast freue
mich sehr dass siemens will bei hier ist
und anderswo dahmani herzlich willkommen
schönen abend haben
es gibt ja leute die sagen riem diese
begegnung mit der kanzlerin damals das
war so eine art schlüsselmoment für
vielleicht sogar auch die aussage von
angela merkel wir schaffen das wie war
das für sie
kann sein dass das in dem moment in dem
bei der bundeskanzlerin etwas besonderes
ausgelöst hat aber ich denke da spielen
auch ganz andere schicksale und ganz
andere entscheidungen die sie vorher
schon getroffen hat eine rolle
wenn das so sein sollte dann freue ich
mich eine gute tat hinterlegt zu haben
wie war das bei ihnen auch ihr foto das
ging um die welt dass alfie mit der
kanzlerin hat sich dadurch ihr leben
verändert denken sie gerne an diesen an
diesem moment zurück das war eine ganz
ganz besondere schule ist moment in
meinem leben als ich das würde gemacht
habe mein ganzes leben hat aber sicher
also komplett verändert so die positive
seite auch gleichzeitig die negative
seite
da ist sehr viel schlimmes erlebt habe
sehr viel schlimmes erlebt weil sie
natürlich auch bekannt geworden sind
durchaus foto und aber wie gesagt eben
auch viele schöne dinge in den letzten
fünf jahren haben sie auch das land
kennen gelernt die die wie man immer
sagt land und leute und auch die kultur
was gefällt ihnen besonders gut an
deutschland fast alles also ich freue
mich sehr hier zu sein ich bin
sehr dankbar ich hatte den chance hier
mit meinem studium angefangen gehen und
dann geht's also ich habe schon mit
meinem studium angefangen
ich habe die jetzt als kleinsten ist
leben hier aufgebaut ich habe meine
wunderschöne wurde und meine
wunderschöne freundin und ich bin sehr
froh hier also abgesehen dass manche
leute mich alles doris genannt haben
aber ich bin kein terrorist ich wohne
hier meine freundin kennen ich also
meinen dass das dritte kind nicht dass
ich ein gutes programm ab man muss eben
die menschen immer auch einzeln sehen
und sie einzeln kennenlernen und
bewerten wie war es für sie die letzten
jahre was zum beispiel wenn wir ihn
gefragt haben was ihm gut gefällt was
finden sie denn nicht so toll in
deutschland gibt es irgendwas wo sie
sagen es nervt mich ein bisschen die
sturen gesetze für die stufen gesenkt
dass man manchmal wirklich nach gesetz
handeln muss ohne die einzelnen
schicksale zu betrachten sie meines auf
die asylpolitik durch ja allgemein auf
die deutschen gesetze genau das finde
ich nicht so gut dann wenn man sich die
einzelnen schicksale angucken würde dann
ja wäre man in der asylpolitik glaube
ich ein klitzekleines bisschen weiter
jetzt sind die beiden aber tatsächlich
beispiele für die gelungene integration
schule studium und vieles vieles mehr
wie verfolgen sie wenn sie gerade schon
auch das politische angesprochen haben
wie verfolgen sie die debatte um
geflüchtete ja also ich informiere mich
da immer in den medien sehr viel drüber
und kenne auch einzelne personen die das
ganze eben selbst erlebt haben und
versuche da ganz ganz viel persönliches
von mir mitzuteilen um einfach auch um
anders zu helfen dann zu helfen und
vielleicht auch fehler zu vermeiden so
dass meine fehler nicht noch mal
begangen werden so eine art
integrationslotsen also von den eigenen
erfahrungen auf was zurückgeben
weitergehen
dass andere menschen wie sie schon
selber gesagt haben vielleicht den einen
oder anderen fehler nicht mal die regeln
wir haben andere regeln teilen als in
ihren herkunftsländern dass man die dann
übernimmt dieses wir schaffen das was
die kanzlerin damals gesagt hat wie war
das eigentlich für sie also für jemanden
der neu in dieses land kommt und diesen
satz hört also ich es war am anfang
natürlich hart ich habe selbst an mich
daran viel hart gearbeitet ich also wir
hatten das besser schaffen können aber
am anfang hatte ich mich gefühlt dass
ich hier herzlich willkommen bin also
jetzt wir sind was in den fünfziger
jahre
die leute nehmen ein bisschen aber
bestand also es ist halt nicht wie
früher
ich hatte nur das besseres gefühl als
wäre sie nehmen abstand zu ihnen sind
vorsichtiger geworden genau viele leute
hätten also hat den jetzt schon angst
wenn ich bin gegen die nachricht hin
aber es gibt auch halt die leute die
wirklich gefährlich sind aber das ist
eine sehr sehr kleines teil verstehen
sie denn die menschen die vorbehalte
gegenüber geflüchteten haben
ich muss also ich hab es was service
meeres mal erlebt ich muss das sehr
bisher leiterin wer ich bin was ich hier
machen würden und was ich mir wünsche
man da verstehen sie halt aber die
grossen teil davon verstehen nicht also
die die halten viele flüchtigen der als
die gefährlichsten aber wer sondern eine
pauschale urteil ist und weil sie nicht
als einzelperson gesehen wäre nämlich
als jemand der in deutschland studiert
mittlerweile wirtschaftskommunikation
möchte ich wo sehen sie sich in sagen
wir sie sind jetzt fünf jahre schon in
deutschland wo sehen sie sich in fünf
jahren ich werde immer besser werden auf
jeden fall schwer denn also mein ich
werde mich bemühen meine studium bis zum
ende schaffen zu können obwohl das sehr
schwierig ist das also auch an der
sprache studieren aber ich stehe mit
ganz viel bis zu drei stunden an den tag
und am ende werde ich mich beworben in
einem unternehmer oder entfernt was mit
medien zu tun hat ich werde meine
familie hier ein laden in meine familie
hatte ich meine familie schon jetzt mehr
als fünf jahre her gesehen
das ist wie es so hart für mich dass ich
hier auf aktion manchmal meter ich würde
sie mal wieder treffen in ferien sind
noch in syrien
nähe von damaskus und wir haben ja auch
gerade in der runde davor gehört das ist
eben ein land wo es auch immer noch
krieg gibt wo sehen sie sich in fünf
jahren abitur abitur steht bevor ich
wünsche mir so sehr dass das die
nächsten zwei jahre gut klappt und ich
dann gut ins studium einsteiger ich
möchte gerne sozialpädagogik studieren
momentan wohl wenn ich das schaffe dann
habe ich glaube ich einen großen traum
von mir erfüllt und ja ich möchte mit
meiner familie hier leben und irgendwann
auch eine eigene familie gründen und
meine hobbys verfallen sie haben es
definitiv erst mal hierher geschafft in
ein sicheres land sie sind angekommen
sie haben ihren weg gefunden und für
ihren weiteren weg wünsche ihnen
natürlich alles gute und an der stelle
kann man auch mal sagen die geflüchteten
die seit fünf jahren in dieses land
kommen da hat jeder zweite mittlerweile
da sind sie gar keine ausnahme
mittlerweile einen beruf ihnen alles
gute toll dass sie heute zu uns in die
sendung gekommen sind und passen sie gut
auf sich auf dankeschön